ein grünen politiker verkündet eine
laufzeitverlängerung der atomkraftwerke
ein minister der partei die er nun
eigentlich im kampf gegen atomkraft
entstanden ist und trotzdem ist die
entscheidung von robert habeck nichts
halbes und nichts ganzes und
wir haben in einem gewissen sinne die
schwierige lage dass wir anfang
september eine entscheidung treffen
müssen die vielleicht im januar oder im
februar ihre konsequenzen nach sich
ziehen
deswegen ist die für mich richtige
konsequenz aus dem gesagten aus dem
stresstest dass wir uns diese option
erhalten
nach dem ende der regulären laufzeit der
atomkraftwerke die beiden süddeutschen
atomkraftwerke in eine reserve
überführen und wir uns diese option
nicht entledigen aber das ist eine
sowohl vertretbare wie notwendige
entscheidung meine ich und so werde ich
ist der regierung beziehungsweise den
koalitionsfraktionen vorschlagen der
groß angekündigte stresstest seit wochen
wartet deutschland auf das ergebnis und
jetzt nun also dass robert habeck will
nach wie vor die drei letzten akw in
deutschland zum jahreswechsel abschalten
aber dann auch irgendwie doch weiter
laufen lassen einsatzreserve heißt das
zauberwort notbetrieb für den moment der
krise wenn also strom engpässe und
ausfälle drohen dann sollen zwei der
drei lkws wieder hochgefahren werden das
problem dabei ist nur akw es lassen sich
nicht einfach binnen stunden hochfahren
es ist also ein gefährliches spiel mit
unserem strom und die frage bleibt was
denn jetzt nun atomkraft nein danke oder
ja bitte in der ampel gibt schon richtig
zoff über diese halb entscheidung von
grünen minister robert habeck
robert habeck druckst und tricks bloß
nichts falsch machen obwohl der
stresstest den netzbetreiber und
bundesbehörden in komplizierten
rechenmodellen und langwierigen analysen
über wochen angefertigt haben
stromengpässe nicht ausschließt sollen
nur zwei deutsche atomkraftwerke
weiterlaufen und dann auch nur im
notbetrieb
das bedeutet die reaktoren isar 2 und
neckarwestheim 2 sollen wie geplant ende
2022 vom netz gehen und dann in einer
bis circa april 2023 andauernden
einsatzreserve bleiben um im notfall
wieder ans netz genommen zu werden wie
lange es dauert um den schlüssel
umzudrehen das weiß selbst robert habeck
nicht das abbrennen wird und wird
ausgesetzt aber sie bleiben natürlich
einsatzbereit so ist gemeint also es
wird nicht der schlüssel abgezogen alle
gehen nach hause und wir warten mal was
passiert sondern das wie ausgeführt für
diese zeit für den winter bleibt das
personal und alle
sicherheitsvorkehrungen da und erhalten
so dass sie wieder hochgefahren werden
können für das dritte derzeit noch
aktive atomkraftwerk emsland im
niedersächsischen lingen bedeutet dies
gleichzeitig auch das endgültige aus wen
wundert's in niedersachsen ist in knapp
vier wochen war für alle deutschen
reaktoren gilt kein streck betrieb keine
weitere laufzeitverlängerung und
definitiv keine neuen brennstäbe
becks akw wyhl beifall gibt es dann
nicht von den koalitionspartnern das
ganze ist eher unannehmbar der ampel
partner ist richtig sauer partei chef
und bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner will schon vor der hwk eine
klare laufzeitverlängerung und auch die
cdu/csu ist enttäuscht vom ergebnis des
akw stresstest bei uns im studio ist
jetzt bildpolitik chef jan schäfer
einsatzreserve notbetrieb in der krise
kommen wir mit diesem manöver jetzt
tatsächlich gut durch diesen teuer
winter durch diese krise also ich glaube
dass robert habeck aufpassen muss dass
er vom wirtschaftsminister nicht zum ab
wirtschaftsminister wird und das hat
gestern diese pressekonferenz in teilen
auch gezeigt robert habeck verstrickt
sich da auch in widersprüche er will
einerseits ein sicheres stromnetz haben
will natürlich dass dieses industrieland
deutschland auch sicher mit energie und
stromversorgung durch den winter kommt
aber beraubt sich gleichzeitig eines
instruments denn das system gerade in
meinem beitrag hier angesprochen worden
sollte es zu problemen bei der
stabilität des stromnetzes kommen was im
winter wenn kein wind weht und die sonne
auch nicht scheint durchaus möglich ist
dann geht s nicht auf schnippen dass man
diese kernkraftwerke hochfährt sondern
es hat er gestern selbst in der
pressekonferenz gesagt dann kann das
schon bis zu einer woche dauern nun ist
es so dass sich diese netz
instabilitäten nicht zum teil tagelang
vor aussehen lassen also es kann
durchaus zu problemen kommen die frage
ist wirklich warum robert habeck dieses
risiko für die deutsche wirtschaft in
der aktuell dramatischen situation
eingeht das ist gerade schon
angesprochen die akw es lassen sich
nicht binnen stunden einfach so hoch
waren im notfall was bedeutet das für
uns für die bürgerinnen und bürger ja
das bedeutet natürlich dass man damit
rechnen muss dass es das ist er vor
allem für süddeutschland interessant und
wichtig zu möglicherweise instabilitäten
im stromnetz kommen kann was dann auch
zu stromausfällen
führen könnte könnte muss man sagen ganz
interessant ist ja dass robert habeck in
seiner begründung auch gesagt hat dass
er hofft dass es eine europäische netz
stabilität gibt und dann die deutschen
kernkraftwerke nur im notfall falls das
europäische netz instabil wird
eingreifen müssten das bedeutet aber
dass er darauf setzt dass in frankreich
die kernkraftwerke wieder auch richtig
gut laufen das ist doch schizophren wenn
man will dass in frankreich
kernkraftwerke laufen in deutschland
selber abschaltet obwohl wir wissen und
das hat der tüv süd uns nochmal
bestätigt dass diese kernkraftwerke in
deutschland die letzten drei zu den
sichersten oder am besten geführten in
der ganzen welt gehören jetzt ist es nur
ein vorschlag von robert habeck gewesen
überzeugt er damit die koalitionspartner
überzeugt dann wird auch vor allem die
fdp nein das habe mir gerade in dem
beitrag ja auch schon kurz gesehen da
gibt es jetzt wirklich ein aufschrei des
koalitionspartners fdp angefangen vom
parteichef christian endter über den
fraktionsvorsitzenden
christian buer beide sagen ganztag das
was robert habeck hier vorlegt land
überhaupt nicht lieber aus der
wirtschaft kritische stimme aber
interessant ist dass man nach dem
wochenende als die koalitionspartner
jahr 22 stunden lang zusammen saßen um
einen leistungsprogramm zu verabschieden
dass man da ungefähr 24 stunden lang
ruhe hat und gehofft hatte diese
koalition den letzten monaten sehr
zerstritten war die kommen nun in
besseres fahrwasser das hat robert
habeck mit seinem auftritt gestern abend
18 uhr vor der presse wie der komplett
eingerissen das wird sich die fdp so
nicht bieten lassen das hören wir jetzt
auch schon und da ist auch wirklich
wieder muss man sagen feuer unterm dach
[Musik]